jared uh your wife uh appeared
on the show yes and uh you murdered her
yes yes yes yes what do you mean what do
you mean
it was an accomplice i wasn't i didn't i
didn't hold the knife he held the knife
all right securely
wait wait a minute so i held her okay so
all you did was hold your wife while
another man murdered her yeah yeah yeah
there was no there was no collusion
illusion
how does that does that ever come up
when you're having an argument with your
wife does it ever come up
or what about the fact that like someday
down the road your kids are going to be
asking hey
what about this scene we just saw on the
internet were you murder mom
yeah yeah that's yeah that's not the
weirdest thing we've done on camera
for the show
let's just say it was it was the last
time he held her and watched yes
[Laughter]
all right i'm curious about something
here's what's unique to your show pretty
amazing
uh characters die but then they come
back okay now there's a lot of shows out
there
famous shows where when they see that
they're dying in the script the actor
is filled with remorse but that doesn't
happen on the set of your show does it
not necessarily i think i've died over
110 times
right yeah and i'm still here yeah yeah
jared you've died i think you've died
it's only six times that's right why is
it that he dies
constantly and you've died relatively i
mean is he just more physically awkward
what happened
i i'm guessing it's half that and also
half
from when i worked with andy on new york
minute yes he taught me some very
amazing
uh very amazing things one was make sure
you don't die more than six times
that's right you guys work together yeah
yeah i haven't seen each other since the
oscar party
the big yeah that's that's that was the
olsen twins
uh they know new york man everyone's
everyone yes
okay it's always good when a crowd gets
real quiet and then you explain to them
what that movie is
you